miranda lambert announces she's engaged  well maybe no Miranda did not say yes to  her 28 year old boyfriend Anderson east  in fact an even younger man asked the  singer for her hand in marriage an  adorable fan popped the question during  a meet-and-greet at her spread the love  tour in New Jersey Saturday on Sunday  Miranda Instagram this shot of a little  boy getting down on one knee with an  engagement ring the country crooner  shared her answer to the sweet gesture  in the caption writing I said yes but he  has to wait 25 years this sweet boy  Sebastian is a little gentleman and we  think Sebastian has great taste in fine  jewelry  check out Brenda's gorgeous pink  sparkler oh you got a rock what you got  well one thing's for sure  Miranda was impressed by her young fan  and maybe my favorite proposal over